me
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
welcome back to the realist podcast in
the dunya the three muslims we're joined
here with a very special guest
leroy kenton how's it going man
doing well how are you guys doing
good man all praise to the most i can't
complain
so before we go in i just want to give a
quick uh little shout out to you you
have a channel you have multiple
channels ftd so i'm sure all the ftd
family that's loyal is here tonight to
tune in um before we go too much in i
want to know a little bit about your
story so
you had a little bit of a relationship
with christianity from what i know you
made a video titled why i left
christianity tell us about it all
there's no you know time limit no
pressure anything that you feel
comfortable with and then i hear you got
some questions for us so god willing we
will answer them all for sure for sure
so yeah a little bit about my background
you're right i i grew up in a christian
household
uh specifically it's a denomination of
christianity known as seventh-day
adventists
and
growing up it was like going to church
it was every saturday not sunday you
know we kept the sabbath similar to the
jews so
friday sunset was you know no more tv
no more work nothing like that all the
way until saturday sunset so that was my
life for 20
plus years and
i
in that time i
got a lot very familiar with the bible
and i started just learning reading
diving into the original languages
learning the hebrew
uh the greek and everything and just
trying to
really understand my religion and
live it out you know to the best of my
ability
and then over time i began to get more
involved with the church my
relationship
with god had started to develop and
everything and i was really curious you
know one of the things that was really
driving me to learn more about my
religion specifically at the time was
uh a verse in genesis uh one in genesis
chapter one where god says he made man
in his image i was like whoa so hold up
you're telling me that
if god made man in his image that means
god must look like something that was my
reasoning at the time
so i was like okay well what does god
look like
and
that strange as it sounds that was
literally my motivating factor
getting closer to god because i just
wanted to know
so
uh fast forward
now um
i
started getting involved with a
particular
group now they're not necessarily
familiar uh affiliated with
the seventh-day adventist religion
but this group of christians that i
started hanging out with uh began to say
that they started hearing messages from
god and you know of course
this is something that i'm like oh
interesting all right well
let me hear more and
the more i hung out with them is the
more
stories i would get of people saying god
told me to do this god showed me this
she sent me a vision of this and
it began to peak my interest and
i'm not gonna lie i was really caught up
in it and there was a particular
prophecy
that there was a massive flood that was
coming right
and this is supposedly coming from god
and
long story short it didn't happen
and after that moment after at that time
i was thinking i'm like
wait a minute here i am thinking that
i'm
getting closer to god here i am thinking
that these people they're hearing from
god and of course if god says
something's gonna happen and it doesn't
happen it wasn't from god because god
doesn't lie
so then i i took us
you know some time to just really check
and say hmm
maybe what i believe
isn't necessarily
all there is to believe maybe there's
more to this religion thing maybe
there's more to hearing from god
you know
and just because i believe in something
really really strongly doesn't
necessarily mean that it's true so that
was my mind
you know my mindset at the time and plus
it was pretty hard because i'm like you
know i i felt like an idiot because
here i am
becoming um you know like one of these
religious nut cases that i see on the
news
you know in a smaller sense
and that was literally the turning point
of me saying okay how about i step back
and
take a look at religion just from an
objective view and just see
and learn
and
that's how
i started to
learn more of islam because growing up
you know
as a christian
i would often hear well
don't read the quran
don't talk to those guys because
you know
one specific instance i remember
somebody told me don't read the quran
because you can get possessed by a demon
so
you know what i mean right so all i knew
growing up was my bubble of religion and
when i decided to
say okay let me take another look i put
that aside and i started to examine
religion in a more
open way so
that's the story in a nutshell of uh
where i am today and why i do what i do
okay okay fair enough
and before i pass the torch over to rami
i just want to know
off the rip all right just for the
record yeah where do you stand right now
in terms of your beliefs right so a lot
of people once they leave a certain type
of
religion or denomination or way of life
or ideology
they kind of feel conflicted man let's
be honest so sometimes there's a lot of
misinformation out there sometimes
there's an over amount of information
right sometimes people say you know let
me take a break from this religion thing
let me you know
agnostic you know atheists or whatever
and a lot of times other people they
leave one religion immediately into
another right so where do you kind of
stand
um
at the current moment i don't identify
with any particular religion
i i do hold some beliefs so that some
people would say well you know that's
held in islam you know that's held in
christianity that
held in hinduism and whatnot
but i currently don't have a religious
label i i've chosen to live my life like
that at least for this period of my life
because with that i found
some freedom you know there's no
pressure to have to gravitate to one
particular ideology or one particular
religious path i can just
observe
and learn and then come to conclusions
after i've examined the details
okay so when you say you don't belong to
any particular way of life or religion
how are you in terms of your i guess
fundamental belief in god
i yeah i do believe in
god
uh i don't believe that god can be seen
though as i previously
believed um
i believe god was
uncreated meaning that
god is eternal always existed can't die
can't sleep you know
all-powerful all-knowing
uh
everywhere all at once
and
everything that could possibly happen
and will happen and has happened
god knows
okay so you believe in in the divine
decree like god knows everything that
has happened will happen continue to
happen
you mentioned one one thing too um
subhanallah it agrees with uh you know
the islamic ideal that we don't believe
god allah to be omnipresent right but we
believe allah to be
um you know in terms of knowledge the
all-knowing the all-wise omniscient
right
being everywhere at once would limit god
and his divine decree like imagine if i
could look at something be like okay
since god is everywhere i could see god
right there right that to me just didn't
say right
but yeah
anyway i'm going to pass the torch over
to rami
all right
oh hello
leroy bro i i'm really happy we could do
this and i'll say why in a second first
i want to give a little bit of a
disclaimer
uh i suffered a mild allergy attack a
few minutes ago so forgive me if i look
or even sound a bit stuffy
uh you know it is what it is it's not
it's nothing new to me but leroy i've
been watching your videos since uh
probably before we started this channel
probably before i started my my personal
channel even so i'm really really happy
that you know we could we can get
together and collab like this
yeah
happy the pleasures ours so
um
first i wanted to ask
in your years of you know research and
religion and stuff what would you you
know kind of summarize that you've found
in your research
uh like in what sense uh just in about
religion in general or um
yeah i would say about about the truth
in general things that
uh you find truthful in certain
religions
okay
so
what i've found is i've come to the
conclusion that there is a god now the
term
god is just an english term
right you know there's so many
words that can be used like allah you
know uh yahweh there there's so many
terms that you can call god the creator
the divine being you know
i found that that is a common theme in
all religions although the the word used
might be
different
you know and
with me what i've also found is that
based on the word that is used
it can
give particular impressions about god
so
uh just to give an example like i
mentioned earlier when i was saying well
if god has made god made humans in his
image that he must look like something
um
but nobody has seen god at it like at
all ever
that
you know referring to god having an
image
creates a particular impression in my
mind that okay he must look like
something right
um
even the term
god for instance has its limitations you
know this capital g lower lowercase g
the term god can be
used for you know somebody of great
excellence and things like that so i
found limitations with uh with language
use um but i do have to uh say though
that the the term allah you know um you
can correct me if i'm wrong but it means
the god right like the the only
god
yeah
yeah so
referring to allah and saying he
all right away
that can leave an impression that god is
a male figure but
how could god be a male figure if god
created male so
those are some of the things that i've
learned language is really important
when it comes to looking at religion as
well as how we interpret what we're
hearing because you may be saying to me
allah but right away i'm seeing some man
in the sky in my brain right
so it's it's just important to
understand
what is being said in each particular
religion and understand it and this is
one reason why i like going to the
source to hear from
you know muslims who live and understand
their religion so you can explain it
because i don't want to be
misinterpreting so that's one thing that
i've found language is 100 important and
also
that
god
exists that you know the teaching and
understanding of god exists those are
two
two big things that i've found so far
yeah yeah that's really great that's
really great because i would say that
the one thing you can find uh whether
people are religious or not is a common
belief in something spiritual or a
common belief in god or the afterlife or
something like that so i'm really really
glad that you can kind of piece all of
that together
and see that commonality and also you
know be critical because there's a lot
of people
that lack that that critical aspect to
their you know
their kind of academic research and
everything or they're critical of you
know one religion one particular
religion and they're not so critical of
another and this is something i've seen
quite a bit with my like live
discussions and stuff so i'm you know
for me especially it's it's really great
to see that kind of criticism from you
uh i think i think it's great
now my second question before we move on
to perhaps some of the questions you
have
my friend is
uh you said that you
don't
uh well i don't want to like kind of
misrepresent what you said but
paraphrasing you don't gravitate towards
a particular religion right
and i was gonna ask is there a reason
behind that i know you mentioned that
there you know it reduces the stress of
kind of having to gravitate towards one
uh but is there a reason you don't want
to gravitate towards one how would you
uh
feel about or how do you feel about
perhaps finding the truth if such a
thing exists with a religion
um
the reason why i i do this is because
the moment i i fundamentally believe
that
each religion
is coming from a particular
viewpoint
right
and
it the moment i start identifying with
one particular
religion i then have to take on that
viewpoint and to me it just wouldn't be
fair for me to have as much of an
objective
view as possible on religions before i
make my decision
uh rather than taking on a religion then
looking through things through that
perspective i can just look and examine
right
so
does that answer your question yeah 100
100 you know i actually i really like
that answer too i really like that
answer i want to propose kind of an idea
to you not i want to hear your thoughts
when it comes to anything we believe in
life right
whether it's a scientific belief a
political belief or whatever um what we
do as humans is we look at the evidence
behind that belief and you'll find that
the evidence that points towards the
truth of one you know stand stance or a
viewpoint
would
by necessity
um
prove the other ones wrong objectively
well not objectively but at least
subjectively to you know in your own
mind so let's say let's say you find the
the big bang model very very convincing
in science then the idea that the
universe is eternal would not be
compatible with that belief by
definition so likewise it's it's the
same with religion even though religions
overlap in terms of beliefs and
everything there can only be
one religion or one way of life
that is true or in other words one truth
if christianity is true then it's
impossible for islam to be true because
one believes in the trinity one
literally specifically outlines the
trinity by saying do not say three
right
uh and same thing with basically i'd say
every other religion so
i guess what i'm trying to get at here
is if you were able to validate one
religion or prove one religion by
necessity it would disprove everything
else so you wouldn't have to kind of
see every single religion
like 100 before making your choice
do you what do you feel like that kind
of solves the i don't want to say
problem that you have with it but would
that wouldn't that make it easier
i would say it's one way to look at it
not necessarily easier um i could see
how that approach could work for certain
people yeah
um because
i don't know based off of how they grew
up or what they've learned the
convictions that they have
um
but me fundamentally believing that
what religion is its own
viewpoint
um
i it wouldn't it wouldn't be okay with
me
yeah right so
let me i'll try to explain it like this
i believe that all the religions they're
pointing to the the
the same fundamental truths now it could
be said differently
but
fundamentally it's there and there could
be a lot of differences uh you know one
where religion may clarify something
better and to say it differently and
what not and
but ultimately i think they all say this
they all point to the same fundamental
truths so me believing that and taking
on a particular religion it
it would be violating that particular
belief i have now one thing about me
though is i understand that this is a
viewpoint that i've taken on it's not
necessarily
the truth right i i don't claim to
say like okay this is the truth or the
only way to look at life and look at
religion and examine things it's just
the way that i've chosen to
live this particular period of my life
um and i found that it works for me
it may not work for somebody else though
yeah
yeah 100 100 and at the end of the day
you know to each their own i'm glad that
you know at least this viewpoint is is
open you know a lot of people's view
points end up being closed off and then
they uh they're kind of stuck like that
stagnate you know stagnant for the rest
of their life and yeah that's not
something anyone wants to be whether
they're religious or not i think
everyone should have the open mind and
be able to look at different ways of
life different
uh you know viewpoints methods of living
and
well you gotta be right you know that's
also part of life you know when we were
five years old look how much knowledge
we've gained since that time and look
how much we've added to our life you
know we've learned so much that we've
expanded and just imagine if we were
closed off to
that just thinking like a five-year-old
and the knowledge that we had back then
right just closed off i i say we got to
be open as humans like we
it's essential to
the survival of humanity to be open or
else you're stuck yeah 100 you know
actually allah says in the quran
that he created us basically
in different i'm gonna paraphrase
different races and different tribes
different traits so that we can get to
know each other that's literally what
allah says in the quran i think that's a
very beautiful passage because it put
the it puts a spin on you know racial
ethnic differences uh in different
traditions even because a lot of people
they become you know racist or
tribalistic
yeah but it's not put to spin on it it
says the whole point of everyone being
different so that you can get to know
each other and basically you know live
in harmony it's very beautiful
so i'm going to go uh grab tissues
because of my uh
no worries bro i'm going to pass it on
to
allah
bro so
when my first song how are you man it's
it's good to have you
i am well watching a lot of your videos
wow
you're doing good work bro for real like
you're doing really good work i like
what you do appreciate that but
yeah man to get into everything
first thing i want to say is that there
was this one scholar that said um
think about
what allah like what god would look like
like whatever you could come up with in
your head
it's nothing like that you're right
like no matter what you can come up with
in your head you'll never be able to
understand and grasp like what
a lot truly looks like and
and
god does look like something we just
won't be able to comprehend it
until like you know we are completely
past this point
and we are no longer in this dimension
in this reality in this life
you know so that's something to think
about
and in regards to what that's something
that uh islam teaches just for my
clarification that islam teaches that in
the hereafter you could like actually
see god
yeah the the people in in heaven the
people in general that would be one of
the rewards actually wow yeah
and it would be something
that would be more beautiful than
anything in this world like think about
the most
beautiful scenery you've ever seen like
maybe let's say you're traveling let's
say you go to um
uh the mild dives
if i said that correctly
you've seen that right where they have
like the little bungalows like on the
the
ocean imagine waking up right there
and then just seeing this beautiful
sunrise the the well the colors in the
sky is like the most intense orange
you've ever seen you're over here
looking at the ocean just serene
beautiful just the most beautiful thing
you've seen
yeah just know that that's just
that's nothing
compared to
uh what will be in jannah will be in
heaven and what allah like what god is
you know because that in and of itself
is just a creation
right so it's
all the creations are meant to be uh
like signs for us
you know if you're truly you know in
tune with it and aware
but aside from that
what i wanted to hit on bro
is
when you were saying
that um
you're kind of looking into
different religions you know
so you can have an objective you
so you're not like fully pertaining to
yourself to one before like
you actually make your decision
right yeah
i think that's great bro i think that's
great because i personally i'm a reaver
and i was there
as well previously
and
i don't know if you've gotten to this
point yet
but when you start to look into
different religions
different spiritual practices different
cultural beliefs
and all that what you run into
is that they all have
pieces of the truth pieces of the puzzle
right like you notice it have you
noticed it or what
they
yeah they complement each other i i find
that yes there's pieces here and there
and all of that
and then sometimes
you'll find something where it's like oh
this has this as well
you know and like the more you look into
different
religions spiritual practices cultural
beliefs the more you'll find this and
what you'll see is that
some have more pieces
than the others
and then the question that arises is
okay well why do some have more pieces
than the others
and then it all goes back to the
telephone game you remember the
telephone game that we played as kids i
remember that you'd go around and say a
word in somebody's video and they had to
tell it and then by the time it goes
around the circle it's a completely
different word you're like wait i didn't
say that
yeah yeah yeah
exactly so bro
god has been playing this game with us
and this is me dumbing it down so if it
sounds crude it probably is because it's
me dumbing it down but it's it's
basically god playing this telephone
game with us trying to
relay the message relay the truth the
answer as to like
we all have these questions like why the
hell are we here
where the hell did we come from what the
hell is coming next you know like what's
the meaning of all this what's our
purpose we have all these questions
everyone has these questions doesn't
matter who you are in this world you
have these questions why do you have
these questions
well god is like okay well let me tell
you
right let me tell you because you all
have these questions there's a reason
why you have it so
ever since the beginning guys been
trying to play this game with us
and the moment god begins to tell us the
answer
the moment we alter
the answer like in a telephone game the
moment we change the word the original
word is game over
right
it's game over
so
what ends up happening is that god is
sending this message god is telling us
the moment we alter it guys that okay
game over
moves on to the next person or the next
group of people and that's why you see
all these different religions all these
different spiritual practices all these
different cultural beliefs have
basically pieces of the puzzle some have
more pieces than the other why because
the ones that have more pieces than the
others they were receiving the answer
for a longer period of time before they
altered the message
and
the more you look into islam and again
this is not me trying to like converse
you avoid you i would never do that i'm
just saying like from my own research my
own experience
the more you look into islam you start
to see all the pieces begin to connect
begin to connect and
ultimately they all connect
there was no alteration of over 1400
years and it's it's yet to be altered
but you look at all the other different
religions spiritual practices at some
point in time there were alterations and
with those alterations came the uh cut
off of the answer cut off of the truth
like bro you look into hinduism you look
into hinduism bro look at how crazy it
is now where they have all these
different idols all these different gods
like it's pretty crazy
you know but when i wasn't muslim i
thought it was actually pretty cool
because i was like wow they're so
spiritual they're so like
peaceful and all that stuff but like
when i started looking into it i was
like whoa
there's something wrong here like
because if you look into like the
ancient veda texts like the original
scriptures
the original scriptures spoke about only
one god
only one god and here they are now with
multiple gods so you see at some point
they altered the message
and leeroy i just wanted to add one
point to brother angel
a lot of people might be on it on the
that you know wave of thinking that okay
why did god just not come down and tell
us face to face like if god wants us to
know the truth why you know play all
these you know send all these messengers
and prophets etc etc that lead to
corruption and lead to alteration and
modification
one not only does this not be fit
allah's majesty right coming down as a
man or
so on like other religions believe but
number two then it wouldn't be a test
it really wouldn't be a test imagine me
asking you okay cool we're gonna have an
exam in like five days all right i'm
going to give you all the questions that
are going to be on the exam and i'm
going to give you the answers too
all right and this test is going to be
in five days everyone would pass it
would not be a test right
you gotta you gotta think too
um
i don't wanna like overload you
but
when you look at different religions
spiritual practices cultural beliefs
uh
when they were receiving the answer the
truth
it's all very simple and easy to grasp
right because it's
it's innate
and they it's inside of us like when we
see something to be the truth when we
like we're like ah yeah like i know this
or well yeah that makes sense
it's because intuitively we already
understood that
you know what i'm saying
so when you see these things and they
make sense
is because they were receiving the truth
at that point the moment that it starts
getting overly complicated
and
you no longer intuitively understand
well that's when you know that
alteration has come into the picture and
like in the beginning once the
alteration sets in
it's game over bro it's like i i said
banana in the beginning and
it's coming back as something else says
eggplant or something like that i'm
sorry bro but it's game over like we
can't continue you know like it has to
start over again
and what's beautiful bro what's
beautiful
is that the uh the prophet muhammad
peace and blessings be upon him
he was actually asked about the um
like how many prophets
or yeah how many prophets came into
existence
and correct me if i'm wrong romney
because i think you know this one pretty
decently this hadith
but it was narrated that he
think it was like around like 129
000
prophets
roamed the earth
and that that's crazy bro and then he
was asked like okay well how many of
them were messengers
and um
he said a far less number
so it's just something to think about
you know
and on top of that we know that every
nation was sent a profit
right so if you think about it every
nation
did get the truth it's a matter of what
they did with the truth now human beings
subhanallah with islam we understand
that we're all born with this thing
called the
have you heard about that
uh
so i repeat that the fitra have you
heard about anything called
yeah what
what do you know from just when you hear
that word
what comes to mind what did you research
it's like
everybody is sort of born with a
propensity to follow
god uh because your baby you're you're
innocent and
you're you're
literally born
more susceptible to just following the
will of god automatically but
over time traditions and culture comes
in and then it sort of changes that
is that accurate that's more or less in
a nutshell what it is it's the innate
predisposition that human beings are
born with regardless of what religion
they're born into right we from islam we
know that every single person that is
born is born a muslim
it's just up to the parents to change
their religion right so
we understand that's why that's also why
you know a lot of people are like why is
it called reaver and not convert it's
called reverb because you're already
born on that innate predisposition
you just revert to that state of your
fitrah later in life
right
but anyway i'm going to let rami take
over now
okay
personally i want to i want to hear what
leroy has to say or if he has any
questions for us definitely uh yeah i i
do actually um
you know i i definitely appreciate the
the standpoint of uh islam and it being
the truth and all the the uh
truth out there is going to eventually
point to islam and all of that
the the question though that i
have for you guys is
what makes islam the truth like for you
personally living
out
lives as a muslim
what is it for you anyways
that was like ah
this is the truth
i think it's i think it's only fair that
we let angel answer it first since he
has been muslim you know
the least in terms of operation
he's the newbie
yeah i'm thinking about it i gotta
gather my thoughts so well i'll go i'll
go quick because mine isn't too long but
in my life i've had a three-step
approach to this right the first step
was let me look at every religion right
even though i was born muslim mind you
right so i'm still not one of those you
know even in the quran right allah says
in the quran don't just you know follow
or believe the religion of your
forefathers because it's the religion of
your forefathers right and allah doesn't
write this to all disbelievers or oh you
know non-muslims right so it's not
excluded just to you know
non-muslims i feel like everyone should
firmly have conviction not blind
conviction not blind faith none of that
over here right
so
i looked at every religion and i
realized most religions have been
corrupted right
they all you know start with monotheism
and now they end up with polytheism i
don't know how that makes sense even
even rationally logically right
if you want to you know rationally or
logically prove the existence of one god
you can disprove polytheism right that's
already done with that everything points
towards one god then you look at other
religions that are like ethnocentric
right like judaism like you have to be
born into it from your mother's side
um in terms of lineage otherwise it's
very hard to convert right so kind of
doesn't make sense then you have other
religions where it's like
they believe in one god but then they
have practices which don't make sense or
there's contradictions right this is
something huge
you have a lot of channels right
that try to paint oh look at
contradictions in the quran all of these
videos all of these you know phonies
have been refuted there's no
contradiction in the quran
none like i challenge anyone right now
to find one contradiction in the quran
right so for me contradiction is a big
thing bro i can't have something that
it's like i want to believe it but then
there's something that doesn't make
sense and then i i don't want to be in
that that position you were talking
about where it's like because i
subscribed or prescribed to a religion
now i have to identify with it so all
the things that don't make sense i kind
of have to you know wear this jersey and
go around acting like i'm on this team
but i'm not really 10 10 those down you
know i don't want to be in that scenario
so i hate that so i looked at every
religion and you know this was kind of
step one all right okay step two was
okay once i'm like all right everything
makes sense in islam everything in other
religions you know there's things that
don't add up cool let me follow islam
but let me kind of be a little
precautious right let me see okay this
thing makes sense this thing makes more
sense this thing makes less sense right
the more i did this every single
question that i had always had a
rational answer not that just logically
makes sense to me but resonated with
within the fitra right it always
resonated with my gut so this was kind
of the second thing right where i was
like kind of questioning everything
testing everything in and ten times out
of ten i always got the answer
then the third you know phase was i've
been in this long enough where i was
like okay every single time i had a
question or a doubt there was always an
answer and i got my clear answer right
so now i just got to work on my
conviction
yeah essentially that was my story okay
so what in terms of working on your
conviction like how would you go about
that like can you clarify that yeah so i
got you bro so in islam right the thing
i love about islam and as muslims right
we can never be bored we have no excuse
to be bored or lazy that we're just
gonna you know sit here and just do
nothing all day we always have something
to do right and it always gives us
purpose and meaning in life when you say
work on conviction in islam we have two
things we have the akida right which is
the belief and then we have the sharia
which is the
laws that govern our way of life think
of it like that when you look at a lot
of different religions religions like
christianity let's say they have akida
which is belief but they don't have
sharia as in you could just believe in
this and then whatever you do
you'll have salvation right to me that
kind of didn't sit well matter of fact i
know you made some reaction videos to
shaykh with many farooq and sheikh man
um was in a debate with uh you know some
christian ladies and he asked them you
know so what you're saying is you could
be a christian you could commit and then
he said a lot of you know heinous acts
that i'm not gonna mention and then
you'll still go to heaven and they were
like yes and to me i was like boom
there you go caught in 4k this does not
make sense whereas here it's like yes
you have the akita you have to be muslim
but there's sharia right there's halal
there's haram there's a way of life and
everything has governance right there
were points where i was like okay why is
this haram does this really need to be
haram and then i realized okay i
understand that either through anecdotal
experience you know or through um
understanding and reason
all right and you actually point to
something um pretty cool
that i've found about uh islam anyways
is that it's
it's pretty
straightforward like what you need to do
and practice it's pretty clearly laid
out and i think that's why we don't see
as many
uh offshoots and islamic sex as we do
see in other religions because there's a
particular
way a train of thought and generally
speaking if you ask a muslim one
question you're generally going to get
the same response back and the source of
where they got it from so i i've
actually found that to be pretty cool
about islam is that it's uh it's like
okay here's a religion bam there you go
this is what you need to do follow it
it's pretty straightforward it's not
like you're kind of making it up as you
go
you know
yeah yeah so everything makes sense so
if you're coming into it with the point
of okay halal haram all of this i think
this is secondary i think as muslims
akida is number one and then sharia is
number two right if you go to someone
and you you tell them here's islam
there's shariah that's
nothing's gonna make sense so the
prophet peace be upon him came with
revelation there was no halal in haram
for a long period of time right and rami
can clarify on the period of time in a
moment but in the beginning it was just
tawheed monotheism right that the
correct belief system i think that's
fundamentally the most important thing
if you don't have that sound everything
else crumbles right in islam what does
the shahada mean i'm sure you've heard
of the shahada you made some videos time
with the yeah the shahada it's not like
you got to go to you know a public place
of worship or you got to pay someone or
do anything right because religion
should not be you know costing you a
dime a shahada is something you can do
in your you know in your bedroom comfort
of your own home no witnesses know no
one
and you just make a testimony right to
god first and foremost that i bear
witness that there is nobody worthy of
worship except allah the one true god
right the one abrahamic god that all
religions point towards
and i believe the prophet muhammad peace
be upon him was his final servant and
messenger that's it that's essentially
what the shahada is and once you become
muslim right just like you're saying
it's very simple we have a clear-cut
path we have the five pillars of islam
right which is like you gotta fast one
time a year right
for 30 days uh you got to go on hajj at
least once in your life which is the
pilgrimage you got to pray five times a
day
um and then there's some other stuff too
you got to give you know zakat with his
which is our 2.5 percent of our income
and all that but even then if you really
think well that's all you fundamentally
have to do as a muslim these are your
five pillars of islam
and that kind of lays the groundwork for
everything else but yeah essentially i
agree with you bro this was it was a
very simple process and now it's kind of
like okay now that i went through all
this trial and error testing everything
out testing the waters now that i'm on
let me just you know do my best with the
time i have in this life
but ami what's your what's your answer
uh so this panel before i go on i just
want to actually say one thing about
zakat it's actually it's not 2.5 percent
of our income it's actually 2.5
of our excessive wealth extra yeah yeah
anything you have extra at the end
so no income tax in islam yeah
i can't give one and like it wasn't like
as far as i know there wasn't a point
where i was like okay this is the truth
islam is the truth it was just
an accumulation of things over time and
as i learned more
i just believe in it more and the reason
i say that is actually there's a concept
in islam
called iman i'm sure you've heard of
iman before right it's uh equivalent to
faith yeah see that's that's the thing i
was just about to talk about that
because that's actually a misconception
that okay even i would say majority of
muslims believe because
iman linguistically means a rational
conviction
so you're convicted of something because
you have evidence and rationality points
towards that being the truth so islam
doesn't actually really have faith or if
it does if it has kind of a faith or a
belief in things that you can't see it's
based on the rational conviction in
islam being true in the first place so
for example okay
if you if you were to like prove the
quran is from god then you would also
prove angels exist because the quran
talks about angels so if you want to
call that belief faith or a belief or
something like that that's fine but it
actually starts with rational conviction
and allah all over the quran actually
appeals to our intellectual way of
thinking our logic our rationality our
mind and these things that we use many
times and it may be in the form of a
rhetorical question do they believe that
they were created from nothing without
to make no sense or were they themselves
the creator of themselves well that also
makes no sense uh did they create the
heavens and the earth no we were born
into the earth uh so that wouldn't make
sense and allah he ends up he he ends up
by saying rather they don't know
anything basically they're not sure of
this at all
and that's the truth but we don't have
any knowledge of this except you know if
god were to reveal it to us himself so
with that concept of iman it's just
something that has been growing and
growing and growing over time for me i
was born into a muslim family but i
wasn't practicing uh i would say for
maybe 16 years of my life
uh all of a sudden i came across a
youtube video talking about shaitaan and
how he became satan and i'm sure you
heard the story about iblis and he's a
jin and all of that i know
that's because i think he did a reaction
or talked about in one of your videos so
i know i know that you do know that part
so um
uh i went to a catholic school by the
way so hearing like you know he was a
fallen angel and all this stuff is you
know
contrary to islam
uh you know i got to
put the two kind of i don't want to say
in combat with each other but you know i
saw which one was true at the end in my
personal opinion uh and then from there
i went i started watching the normal
like speaker corner videos and the bass
and all that and something that really
really struck me even to this day is
i barely ever i'm not gonna say never
but i barely ever see a muslim
struggle to defend the islamic position
and they're humans like humans will not
know things there are things that i
don't know right humans will possibly
not know things and then mess up and
look bad or whatever just because they
themselves don't know the answer but
even with that being the case i barely
ever saw a muslim struggling and that's
something that also boosted my my iman
is very similar to fayad because you
hear these like you know david wood and
like all these people with like oh this
is the contradiction in the quran and
you know these things they they hurt
your iman because now it's like you have
rational evidence against islam and then
you go to one of these you know these
days people who give dawah and teaches
them and everything and they clarify it
in a way that's so clear and concise
down to like every arabic word and what
it translates to and the dictionary they
got it from or the poem that some poet
wrote 1400 years ago and how he uses
that word in this context like it's so
deep and honestly i would say eloquent
that
i i can't look at a david wood video and
be like yeah that's a good breakdown of
you know this verse in the quran from a
non-arabic speaker to begin with so
that's something that really struck me
and boosted my email
over time
so i would say
that's
you know a relatively
uh well summarized version of my story
yeah that's very uh interesting you kind
of touched on
another question that i was gonna ask
but uh
i just want to give angel
some time to uh
share his
uh view of why you know what makes islam
true to him and then i'm gonna go ask
that question perfect
yeah bro do you mind
repeating the question
so for you like what makes islam the one
true religion
because it's it's different hearing it
uh
it's different hearing it in concept but
you know hearing your individual story
your individual story and experience
it's it's a different
vibe you know
so i want to hear from from you like
what was that that
you only saw islam that made it the one
true religion
yeah i i just had to clarify like i had
to make sure i was you know gathering
the right thoughts here yeah gathering
for something else
but it's it's a very hard answer to give
because i have so much that i want to
say
but i would bring it down to
the fact that islam
speaks to our logic
and our intuition
right so
it's very logical in the sense that it's
it's simple
you understand you you can grasp it and
it's like okay here this is this this is
that um do this do that you know it's an
instruction manual like i had made the
example in my reverb video where it's
like imagine you ordered a bed frame
from ikea
and then imagine that that bed frame had
no
manual no instruction manual like you'd
probably be there for a long time trying
to figure that out
you know you might get it done you might
not get it done and if you do get it
done there's a high chance that it's
probably gonna be messed up in some way
shape or form
you know so
i like that about islam that it makes it
very logical and
uh you can go back
you can go back and you can see for
yourself okay there's no alterations
like it's all just clear it's clear
clear clear clear and even the things
which are
not clear
which me and romney we spoke about this
he he was teaching in class
um
it's called danny and
and the ones that are clear-cut like
it's like yo this is it hundred percent
and then the ones that aren't clicker it
it gives you room
to use your your your logic to be able
to interpret your then in islam they
call your o'clock
it gives you that
that that space to use your intellect
because god says in the book many many
times he's like do they not reflect do
they not reflect like reflect like think
about this bro he's not saying just
accept blind you know he's saying think
reflect seek the answers
look for yourself
you know so for me like logically that
made so much sense and the more you get
into it bro
you understand
so many things where it's like
you can never have
the uh concept of many gods
without there being one
all supreme god
right so there's this one guest that we
had his name was faraz zahabi do you
know him
no
i probably seen
yeah do you by any chance watch uh ufc
yeah sometimes
do you remember the fighter named uh gsp
georgia st pierre
yeah yeah yeah
for us the hobby was his coach
okay okay okay
yeah so he he's a muslim as well but he
he's really into philosophy
and
the thing that he had said on the um i
don't know if he actually said it on the
park as or i think he did actually but
he called it the um
he basically i'll try to explain it very
simply here but he says that you can't
have the idea of multiple gods without
the idea of one god and it's basically
saying that like
you you can't have the god of war
without having war and without having
god
right because if i tell you oh think
about a mountain you can think about a
mountain you've probably seen the
mountain you've heard of it all that
good stuff right if i tell you to think
about gold you can think about gold
you've seen it you probably felt it you
heard about it you read about it all
that now if i tell you okay now think
about a gold mountain
you've never seen a gold mountain
there in in in this reality as we know
it there's no such thing as a gold
mountain
but you can put
your collection of amounts in your
collection of gold together to create
some kind of imagery within your head of
what it might look like right and that's
what when you have all these like
impolities polytheism when you have all
these different gods
that's what it is it's just
it's humans trying to put together all
these things but then it all comes back
to one god
there's one god in order for there to be
multiple in this ideology there has to
be one god so you can see again like how
i was talking about before where
it's been the telephone game
the answer is just
the truth has been trying to come to us
at all times
so that's what i like about it the
logical aspect and then the intuitive
aspect where it's like
if you were to strip everything away
my brother if you were to
let's say you were to take like a month
off from work a month off from
everything in your life and just go
traveling abroad
and
or just go into nature just go for like
uh a camping trip for like a month well
it's a long ass time for a championship
but let's say you went for like a month
for a camping trip
if you disconnected from everything you
had no social media no phones no
electronics no one talking to you all
the time it's you just
in like this little almost mini
isolation
what is happening is like you start to
come
to the answers
yourself you know you start to
grasp everything and things start to
make sense you know where before things
made no sense now things make sense and
it's crazy because you just all you're
doing is
basically simplifying your life making
it as simple as possible eliminating all
the distractions so when you eliminate
all the distractions
the answers that come to you
are the answers that are in the quran
why is that because remember how i told
you it's like it's intuitive
meaning that whatever is coming to you
like
it was already meant to come to you like
god has already
revealed this and
it's so beautiful to see that
intuitively if you just remove
everything like
the answers
are there and then when you start going
to look for the answers again you can
see like okay which one's aligned with
those answers that were coming to me
when i was in this isolation when i
stripped everything away i mean even the
the prophet muhammed peace and blessings
be upon him like he received
the revelation
when he stripped everything away
so i mean it's just to me bro that's
that's that's why bro
and i just wanted to add something there
to the beautiful points brother anaheim
presented that
isa prophet isa alaihi
jesus right we we believe jesus to be
prophet not divine not god
um also we
people don't know this but there's a lot
of similarities between christianity and
islam right so we believe in you know
maryam alaihissalam or mother mary right
matter of fact there's a there's a whole
surah
in the quran a whole chapter just on you
know
some
um and we believe in he says some but
anyway
when he would pray it would be in sujood
the position when you're you're kind of
kneeling down you're on your knees and
your heads down um you know on the floor
on the surface that's the position that
we pray and that's the prophet that's
the position prophet isa all the
prophets would pray
and as a matter of fact i always
recommend people that people that are
unsure about their their conviction you
know they they kind of have the rational
conviction like angel's saying maybe
they don't you know go out in nature and
form that you know emotional fitra
connection yet
i always tell them just go into sujud
just even if you don't know how to pray
even if you don't even know what you're
doing but if you're sincere go into that
position no one has to be with you it
can be in a dark room it could be at
night no one will be there you don't
have to tell anyone and just
ask god right in whatever name you call
god
and just ask god to guide you to the
straight path
right don't have any expectation don't
say you know allah or god make me a
muslim anything just guide me to the
truth guide me to the straight path
and people are surprised usually more
times than not where they end up
you know i'll leave it at that
yeah it's great to hear uh each of your
uh
experiences and
uh with me you know i kind of get to see
the religion from
in a different way you know it's a lot
more relatable right
um
yeah the question i was gonna
ask relates to you know what we've been
talking about here
uh when it comes to giving dawah and uh
the purpose of dawa you know we see a
lot of people
given dawah you know but
to me a lot of times it looks like just
bickering um insulting other religions
and um
you got you guys probably know like if
you've seen any of my comment sections
on videos you'll see a lot of it not
just from muslims
but also from people of different
uh faiths but just um since we're
talking about islam now like what is
what is giving dawah how should it be
done
and
the end goal of dawa giving dawa is it
to
create a revert
uh what is is it to help change a
person's mind
is it you know
make the world muslim like what what's
the purpose of dawah how do you do it
that's that's a great question that's a
beautiful question so actually i wanted
to mention something that ties into both
um both questions that were asked so
what i want to add is that
some something people don't really talk
about
islam is just beautiful like it is just
beautiful the quran the recitation the
message is all just heartwarming it's
heart-touching it's it's you know
tear-jerking it's it's it's beautiful
subhanallah and that's also a reason
honestly why i'm a muslim because allah
in the process time he said that allah
is beautiful and he loved he loves
beauty
and he said that telling us to like you
know just nicely and look good and stuff
uh but i would even extend it to the
quran that the quran is just a beautiful
thing that you know god created us with
emotions and he revealed the quran that
definitely definitely plays on our
emotions in a good way in a way that it
should because there are things that
we should be emotional about you know
the existence of god it should be
emotional to us
without him we wouldn't even be here
right it's a very beautiful thing
and the same thing is with the dawah
it's supposed to be in a beautiful
manner uh dawah linguistically means
invitation or to invite that's okay
invitation all right yeah so when you
give dawah to people you're basically
inviting them to islam to the truth to
believe in one god to worship him alone
to submit to him fully and to follow the
way of life that he's given because he
knows what's best and he's completely
unbiased god by definition cannot have a
bias because he there's nothing that can
benefit him in any way
and he's all-knowing
so he just knows what is best and he
created the universe in
a very particular way
where you know we can both admit that
there there's a good way to live in a
bad way to live you know it's not it's
not great to live in a way where i'm
constantly putting myself in harm's way
in danger you know that's my you know
and everything uh so it would be better
better to avoid that so there are ways
to live that you know people would say
are better or worse and but objectively
only god can really tell us that so this
is essentially the message of islam that
you worship one god alone with him fully
and that you take as an example the
prophet muhammad peace be upon him which
leads me to my next point about dawah
insulting bickering none of that is
actually islamic
even the arguing part the prophet peace
be upon him he said i guarantee a house
in paradise for the one who gives up
arguing even when he's right
really yeah and you know what take that
i'll give you the source for that leroy
every time you see a muslim bickering
put the hadith
and if they keep going then you know i'm
going to keep that in my back pocket and
just bam you know
it's it's beautiful and um
i mean it truly is beautiful because at
the end of the day like
the prophet peace be upon him
he's our example allah says in the quran
that we revealed the quran we revealed
the book we revealed i forget the exact
word that's used but basically we
revealed the quran so that you can
explain it to them
meaning that and in other verses saying
that he is basically he's our example
that if we have any disputes we have to
go consult him or in our case read the
hadith about his life
and then basically do what he did and
take him as an example and also obey him
in what he commands because god says
obey allah and obey the messenger
and when we see his dawah it was always
eloquent it was always beautiful and
there's narrations like you know he's he
said a few words but you know basically
with those few words he said a lot you
know me i can go on for hours about one
point and finally hit my point after
speaking a thousand words the prophet
peace be upon him he would say few a few
words and make a very outstanding point
that's i would say all-encompassing and
this is how muslims should give dawa in
a way that's clear concise not
overbearing and with emotional
intelligence with the emotional
intelligence the prophet peace be upon
him had arguing insulting and all that
stuff is not
the sunnah it's not the way of the
prophet peace upon him it's not the way
of a muslim if you look at musa
moses what does
allah prays be to him tell musa to do he
says go to
this is the person who is probably the
the worst individual in history
that people can know of especially from
an ascending perspective
hearing about everything he did probably
one of the worst people in history allah
commands moses to go speak to him kindly
if we were in front of someone like you
know genghis khan or hitler we're not
going to be like yo habibi how are you
no we want to cut them out you know
exactly exactly that's that's how we we
would want to act because there are you
know random people but allah knows that
the character of a muslim is supposed to
be above that supposed to be even though
they're horrible people
maybe even if it's not generally for
them maybe at least do it for yourself
maintain a kindness and a level of
sincerity for yourself at the very end
but regardless god tells moses speak to
him kindly
and if you look at abraham his father
was a person who created idols for
people to worship
so when abraham had to go to his own
father and preach you know dawah and
everything preach islam and teach
basically worship one god alone
his father turned him and said you know
i took care of you my whole life and
this that the other abraham basically
commended his father and appreciated
that fact that he took care of him all
of his life
but still you know invited him to islam
without compromising his belief or
insulting his father so
uh when you look at the prophets upon it
was the same thing allah says in the
quran
i'm going to paraphrase don't insult you
know the other gods don't assault their
gods
lest they insult allah so that you know
they don't end up insulting allah
because we know that this game back and
forth arguing insulting is not something
that's that's beneficial at all and it's
definitely definitely not the way of the
muslim and the muslim should take the
the
example of the prophet prophet peace be
upon him and give doubt in the most
beautiful way that's mine and
i just want to add one thing too if
you're wondering is there an obligation
to the dawah so the prophet saw tells us
convey from me even if it's just one
ayah even just one verse in the quran
right
but those that don't want to study you
don't want to do that the only thing
that you got to worry on is your o'clock
your character leading by example
because people will notice your
character before you open your lips
right so that's highly key so these are
the things we're told to do in terms of
dawah and why wouldn't you want a guide
to some you know guide people and then
your friends and peers and family
members and people that you love
to the truth if you really do love them
right
and you know uh thanks for uh
you know just seeing what she said and
you know clarifying dawah how it's
supposed to be done
this was actually something that i've
i've said in in my previous videos
where
i'm like okay well why not lead with
something that is beautiful about
your religion and why not just lead with
that because that that in a way is more
appealing for somebody to hear because
ultimately yes uh i i understand the the
standpoint that
muslims believe islam is 100
true right but
that's not the belief for the majority
of people on in the world right the
majority of people in the world are not
muslim
uh they don't believe islam is the truth
so in sharing the message there needs to
be some sort of beautifying not
necessarily watering down what islam is
but some sort of beautifying because you
have to be responsible in the sense that
a person may interpret what you're
saying
incorrectly if you come at it i've come
at them in a certain way right so i've
talked about this in videos and um i've
gotten some responses were saying that
well it's the truth you should just say
the truth
you know
anything to add to that like
can you say yeah so a lot of people have
this the truth hurts so kind of suck it
up or deal with the type of mentality
that's the truth you know deal with it
yeah yeah so there's there's a wonderful
i always recommend them to everyone his
name is
he's from uh wales cardiff in in you
know uk if anyone of our uk peeps that
are familiar with that and he always
says this wonderful thing and he always
brings quranic evidence and he always
brings empirical scientific evidence and
he presents the idea that human beings
we have two ways of being influenced
right emotionally and rationally right
and he says too many times more often
than not if a human being has an option
that is emotionally appealing so let's
say everyone else is doing it social
acceptance validation they feel it right
or something that's different which is
rational more often times than not
they'll pick the one that's emotionally
fulfilling and influencing right because
that's the nature of our fitrah that's
how we are designed
one of the first things allah is going
to ask us um you know on the day of
judgment
and and look at is our heart do we have
a sound heart if we have a sound heart
everything else is going to be easy if
we don't then may allah protect us from
that right so a sound heart a pure heart
what does this even mean right
understanding it is one thing but
knowing that when you want to influence
others
having a proper etiquette or an islam is
the way a lot of these keyboard warriors
and fitness warriors fitness just means
trials or tribulations right so a lot of
these fitna warriors and a lot of these
nobodies online they love you know
talking you know what i talking the big
talk when it comes to walking they don't
know much right so they might present a
lot of things in improper ways to you or
you know in other channels and they'll
spread hate and just fitnah all around
and honestly we at t3am bro you already
know what we do bro just quickly block
we got no time for that but aside from
that we love to spread positivity and if
you're wondering why we do that because
that's really what islam teaches right
and you shouldn't judge and this is to
everyone you shouldn't judge any
religion based on the followers you
don't judge islam on the muslims you
don't judge christianity on the
christians right there's a lot of things
that let's say christians muslims jews
have done that are heinous crimes and we
don't judge a whole religion based on
that right these are select few
individuals that are corrupt right so
similarly in islam if there's you know
muslims that are going around sideways
trying to tell people hey this is the
truth you know either you're either with
us or against us
it is what it is right then it doesn't
represent islam and it doesn't represent
the islamic way
of or the sun of like giving dawah
yeah okay yeah that's what i've come to
realize too there's there's a
distinction between the religion itself
what the religion is what it teaches
and somebody who
identifies with that religion you know
there's it's a clear distinction yes
you're right so it's never fair to judge
a particular religion
just on the followers right and
that's that was a lot of um
the the feedback i was getting from
people who weren't muslim when i said
i'm going to start learning more about
islam because right away they're
thinking whoa you're going to get
brainwashed you're going to get you're
going to convert you're going to you
know start yelling all these stuff and
you know um
i'm still waiting for them that happens
brother you know when i get there
yeah so you know there's a lot of
that because
i i think they've looked at the actions
of a few people who don't
necessarily represent islam
and judge the entire religion based off
of that but it's not it's not fair you
know and other religions get a big pass
you know there's a lot of
jews
christians have done some bad things but
people don't necessarily write off the
entire religion so what do they do to
islam
you know it was a question that i've
always
wondered
yeah i want to quickly just you know
tackle that point and then pass it on to
rami but yeah the reason habibi is it's
not profitable today in today's society
right islam
is not you know the profitable answer
when you look at it in hindsight right
if let's just let's just do an access
for simple sake i if islam was the truth
right if islam was the one and only
truth right
and the mass mainstream media right the
main political powers the ones that are
in control the government right big
pharma all of that
if they want to keep controlling us make
as much money from us as possible
right would they be more likely to
promote this ideology of islam
or would they be more likely to demonize
it
because when you demonize it people
don't study it and when people don't
study it they don't enslave themselves
to allah the creator they enslave
themselves to
another man or a bank or a mortgage etc
etc right so there's a huge if you just
look at most of the decisions being made
worldwide
it's all for the benjamin's bro nobody
cares about the truth they care about
what's profitable
yeah very true very very true uh there
were a few things i wanted to mention
the last question but i you know want to
give the mic to angel fiasco anything to
add
yeah i was gonna say that um
in regards to
uh the dawah it's not really
beautifying it because it's
again you're calling to islam islam is
already beautiful the truth is the truth
it
we got to look in terms here to what
rami has said before where it's like you
know what if you don't know about islam
then let your dawah be your character
right right your character
now if someone is
they don't know about islam
or maybe they do know about islam maybe
they started it man like god bless them
for studying it and gathering this like
knowledge
but then
they have a character flaw
because the way that they express it
when they're trying to talk to people
about it it's either too harsh or it's
just too much
and this is where emotional intelligence
comes into play like when you speak to
people you meet them where they're at
you know you don't meet them where you
want to be you meet them where they're
at so like
if they're
ignorant and they don't know like you
wouldn't thrust everything on to them
if they are closed off or they're
hesitant you wouldn't try to force them
into making a decision right away no
it's it's about having the emotional
intelligence and understanding okay
where is this person that you know if i
am going to give that were like what's
the best dollar that i can give okay um
maybe the best dollar right now for me
is not even speaking about islam maybe
it's just me being genuine to them maybe
it's me doing something for them right
like there's this guy here like i'm
staying in thailand right now and in
this little community here
um he's looking into islam
but he's
kind of hesitant you know he's kind of
hesitant and
i noticed like
for him bro like the best dollar has
just been
just random acts of kindness girl like
i cooked the other day in the barbecue
and i
set aside some of the uh the salmon and
the potatoes and i brought it to my like
here bro i made this for you
and it's like bro he he was so ecstatic
he loved it you know it's like that that
was that was in and of itself
you know but at no point did i mention
islam you see what i'm saying so it's
like
again it's not beautifying it's more so
like
it's more so emotional intelligence and
then
i'm actually knowing islam and if you
don't then you know just like characters
speak for itself and if your character
has flaws then you gotta work on it you
know that's what the beautiful thing
about islam is that it's always making
you work on yourself
[Music]
sam hashimi writes fires bengali on jo's
latino
here
is true man far too few people
unfortunately bro unfortunately may
allah change that but unfortunately
they're just too concerned about you
know logically you know that best
perfect philosophical argument
when someone just might want you to take
them off for pizza bro
you know
that type of
brotherhood that type of unity you know
we do have that definitely but for
focusing and privatizing more of that
can only benefit us
right i've heard of a lot of people you
know they're like i accepted
christianity because they had a free
lunch at the church yeah i've heard
stories like that too right yeah oh
trust me and it's like
okay bro if the free lunches is all it's
going to take you then what does that
show
it says a lot about the person why are
you believing the whole ideology on a
free lunch but
it also gives you this idea this truth
that
sometimes people just want to be catered
to
and taken care of and and it's almost
like it opens up their fitrah because
the fitra is our heart right it's tied
to our heart and our heart it responds
better to you know being addressed
instead of our brain being addressed
before bro before rami goes in i want to
give this uh
this thing that happened to me but it
was the most beautiful thing because in
islam like which we everyone has family
you know your brothers your sisters like
we treat everyone as families and
we're supposed to also treat than the
people who aren't muslims as well as
family you know
up to the best of our ability
and in this situation i was already
muslim but this one brother had invited
me over to uh come eat right and we had
a whole bunch of brothers there
and they had like pizza they had wings
and some other stuff you know like they
had something like that nice cuisine as
well
and i saw the pizza they had and it was
like it was like pineapple
with uh something else i was like oh man
that looks good though
and like unfortunately i'm lactose
intolerant so i can't really eat pizza
or it's like my stomach just gets
crushed bro oh man and then like he he
was like oh you want i was like oh bro
like i wish but like i i'm like toast
and tolerant
and then he's like ah
he bro like he just he went like that
and he just like nodded his head
and like he didn't he didn't say
anything else so i would have
and then i remember like we were all
like serving our food and then this man
grabbed like
seven pieces of pizza
and he was like one after the other i'm
like damn bro like you about to go in on
that pizza
as soon as as soon as i said that he
just looked over at me and he just went
back down and like started doing
something i'm like alright whatever like
he's you know he's focused on the food
you know like let him do his thing and
like
within like three minutes bro
he just
put like three four pieces i think it
was three actually he put three pieces
of pizza on my plate all the cheese gone
but with all the toppings on it
and i was like damn bro like
that's what you were doing i'm over here
thinking like you were just hungry and
you wanted to have like more pieces of
pizza but this man literally
took all the cheese off those pieces
just for me like that i was like man
like that that spoke volumes bro wow you
see what i'm saying
and bro
it reminds me of what lyra was saying
earlier oh this was off call actually
the first part was on call he was saying
that everything is predestined you know
nothing happens by chance and that's
what we believe but before the call
before ramadan even made it on i was
talking to leeroy and subhanallah we
grew up like five minute drive literally
yeah like neighbors pretty much
literally neighbors and no one even knew
this but it's like leroy
all of this that's happening bro none of
this is happening by chance right and i
know like growing up bro all the you
know the toronto and mississauga you
know schools we went to
there were a lot of events right so to
speak a lot of boring events yeah
student council events and all these
nobody would show up right but what did
they always offer free pizza right they
always said free pete and bro how many
people just went there for pizza right
there for the food yeah that's what it
is and uh we have a comment from a
sister she writes my friend almost
reverted because he found out on eid we
get money and that was his reason
that was like sixth grade and i was
excited so savannah it really goes to
show like a lot of people like they need
to be warmed up first right you don't
just go you know in for you know logic
and all these perfect philosophical
games those are necessary right but
non-muslims they don't see that they
don't know the quran they don't know the
hadith this was this was a quote by
khabib they look at muslims and their
actions and how they their you know
etiquette and all that
yeah and i was even
reacting to a series of the life of
prophet muhammad and what i learned
is that the the revelation
came
in chunks right
and
the the muslim view is that
if everything came at once would have
been too much to handle so
you know if
even god is
giving this revelation to a prophet in
stages not all at once in stages
you know how much more so in when giving
da'wah
for people who know nothing about islam
or anything like that you know it's
in stages
yeah yeah
this this is this is the thing about
gradualism right so we have we have a
a very frequent guest um i don't know if
you know his name is gabriel el romani
and we have them on our channel a lot
and a lot of people surrounded out there
like you should you know rename your
channel to the four muslims and just
bring them on as a regular panelist but
gabriel he always said this one thing
because you know he's a romanian guy you
know born into christianity he's been
muslim for like 19 years now and he's a
student of knowledge and alhamdulillah
and he always said this one thing that
people lack gradualism yes we got to put
our foot on the gas when push comes to
shove but this whole theory of
gradualism not okay i'm a muslim now so
i got to pray five times a day yes you
still have to pay pray five times a day
but start with one you know yes you you
gotta we gotta dress more modestly but
start slow don't burn out this whole
thing of gradualism it is the sunnah and
just like you were saying revelation
came in pieces right there was no halal
on haram for i believe the past first 14
years right um someone can correct me if
i'm wrong but all these things came in
pieces because we know that if you go
from one way of life to something
completely different which is a stark
contrast most people would burn out bro
we're all human beings at the end of the
day
i actually i just want to jump in here
and comment on something gradualism is a
difficult topic because
although people have the shortcomings
everyone does even me after practicing
you know for years i have many many
shortcomings unfortunately but it is
what it is everyone has their
shortcomings the beauty of islam is that
allah he says
he says tell my believing servants who
have transgressed against themselves by
either there's two ways to sin either
you do something god says don't do
or you don't do something god commands
you to do right and we call this for
obligations like your five prayers the
obligation
and any time you slip up in sin in
either scenario by doing or not doing
he says don't despair on the mercy of
allah
in allah
says indeed allah forgives all sins and
it is him who was the most forgiving
most merciful so although people should
gradually
learn more over time and you can't just
dump everything on you at one point when
it comes to the obligations and this is
how islam is created
people should jump to them
basically to be able to fulfill them
asap if they can't if they fall short
god is merciful god is forgiving you ask
for forgiveness you try you do your best
but god has set a standard for us five
daily prayers fasting ramadan
um going to hajj if you can at least
once in your life so we can omit that
because you can do that at any point in
your life and uh 2.5 of your excessive
wealth you know your savings and
anything you don't need to survive but
you have things like that
and you know subhanallah if you think
about it allah makes it you know
relatively easy from that perspective
it's actually not difficult once you get
into the habit of fasting it's not
difficult it's actually very rewarding
in this life and in the next
uh and on top of that allah says that
fasting is the one thing that the reward
from it you know comes from basically
directly from him in a way i think that
paraphrase that hadith fairly well um
subhanallah but even with that being
said there are still benefits of fasting
in this life and there have been you
know research done on that essentially
for sure yeah and islam yeah allah has
made it beautiful i want to comment on
one thing that you know we kind of
drifted away from but i think it's
beautiful
so one thing actually i want to answer
first is you you ask what the goal is
when we give dawah thanks for bringing
that yes i did ask that yeah what is the
goal yeah thanks for catching that yeah
of course of course um
a lot of muslims would say the goal is
to you know have people convert and so
on and so forth but
uh that's not in our hands so you i
would say that although it's what we
want that's what we desire we love for
people to come to the truth we believe
islam is the truth it's the most
beautiful thing for us i watched one a
video of one sister who who was giving
her shahadah
and the the sister that was helping her
give her she had that she was sitting
there crying because she was so happy
that her friend and her sister is coming
to the truth now it's
so beautiful and that's how muslims
genuinely feel or the vast majority of
them those who give out that's how they
genuinely fear feel when you know people
accept islam but the goal is just to
invite them just to tell them the truth
and you know it's not in our hands
whether they accept or not you know it's
up to you know them if they're genuine
sincere if they want to accept and allah
at the end of the day subhanallah praise
be to him to guide the people and i want
to kind of end on one hadith
um about the prophet peace be upon him i
am
pretty sure that this is authentic i've
never heard any kind of
um dispute that is authentic
but i don't remember the source now
uh basically the son of one man
who was not a muslim the son was a
muslim but his father was a non-muslim
he might actually have been an enemy of
islam i think it might have been abu
jahl but i'm not sure so for now i'll
just say a non-muslim the son wants the
prophet peace be upon him and the son
just accepted islam but his father
actually ended up dying in a battle that
they waged against muslims
um i think it was the bible but allah
knows best and he basically you know
he's still sad because he still loves
his father it's his father even though
he acknowledges that his father was
wrong and he asked
um you know what what's going to happen
to my dad basically you know what's
going to happen to him
and the prophet peace be upon him you
know his answer was so beautiful he said
he said your father is in the same boat
as my father
your father is in the situ the same
situation as my father
um
and that that empathy you know that that
care and that kind of answers is so
beautiful i think it's such a beautiful
precedence
for muslims when they give dawah that
they shouldn't be like oh you know he's
going to hell you know well you know
i'll see you at the measure on friday
peace that's so that's so brutal it's so
rude the prophet peace be upon him peace
and blessing be upon him
he wasn't like that as a person i think
that's what we have to try and emulate
it's the best of our ability
hmm and what i'm saying is facts what i
was mainly saying was in in you know as
a whole it's better to be a good muslim
than a bad muslim of course right but
it's better to be a muslim
even if you're not the best muslim than
a non-muslim once you come to the point
where it's like okay this is the truth
and this brings me to the point where a
lot of people have paralysis by analysis
and they have a lot of pressure when
they want to take the shahada or become
muslim once they get to that point and
my invitation is all the people that you
know they have the the whispers from
shaitaan telling them you know you're
not a good muslim yet you know you can't
pray five times a day who are you to
become muslim right why should you
become muslim wait till your your life
is better wait till your life is more
optimal right and my advice is you're
never gonna get to a point where you're
perfect you know you're never gonna get
to a point where you know everything
right take the step
and don't worry about being seen seemed
as a hypocrite or you know i'm muslim
but i still do this x y and z
taking the step in and of itself is the
one thing that might get you to stop
doing these things right because now is
that cognitive dissonance that oh if i'm
a muslim i have these standards i can't
be engaging in xyz anymore right it's
not fixing these things then turning to
lights always turning to allah first and
foremost in everything
right very very well put
um
just some final comments that i wanted
to just uh
throw in there um i think you guys are
doing a really really good job honestly
finding your channel was like a breath
of fresh air i i definitely feel the the
genuineness
from you and
you know the the whole thing is i really
want to encourage people to just
share
their religion and draw closer to their
religion because
you know in this case if islam is the
truth
and it is the most beautiful thing then
why not just embrace it and grab on to
it right and and share that with people
and if it's truth it will be the truth
if it's not the truth then it won't be
the truth you know it'll fizzle away and
pass so i always want to
encourage that in people and when i see
it happening it's like wow i'm excited
i'm not even muslim but i'm excited you
know what i mean um
so that's who i am and i i think you
guys are doing a phenomenal phenomenal
job keep up the
stellar work and uh you know thanks for
inviting me on likewise bro likewise and
uh i had a quick question for you bro
before we ended up
for someone that's in
you know
a very seasoned veteran at clickbait
like yourself
what do you think of our clickbait game
bro
click big game give us give us your
honest criticism bro i say you
have a good balance of click bait
personally i think it could be a little
bit more but um
the whole the whole thing is with the
with clickbait is it's
clickbait is something that compels
people to click your video because
you have a video of value that you want
to share it's just like a movie poster a
billboard advertising a restaurant you
want people to see your video because
you have something important to share
right
so
never you know your clickbait i think it
could be stronger uh
if you know if i'm being honest i'm here
thinking we gotta tone it down bro but
it's good to hear that bro
anyway we got one last question from a
viewer you're free to answer or deny
just like he says but is there something
islam teaches and or practices that is
deterring you from accepting islam and
this is brother anthony he became muslim
about three weeks ago alhamdulillah so
let us know bro is there something that
islam teaches that's deterring me
not necessarily
based on my studies nothing specific yet
what deters me is
my belief that it's
an
a religion
and i don't identify with
religions right now right you know so
that's the only thing i i'm not against
islam in any way i think it's uh it's a
beautiful religion i think it's very
simple the message is plain
some of my favorite people are muslims
you know uh
that i speak with on a regular basis
so yeah nothing nothing specific it's
just based off of my standpoint that i
live
my life right now on
that's the only thing if you would say
that's deterring me but it's not just
to islam it's all religion it's it's
like it's blanket across the board and
again that may change but currently
that's where it is and until
you know i learn and i'll see where this
particular
moment or particular time period in my
life leads to
and
then take the next step from there
fair enough
all right
everyone who viewed the brothers on here
in leroy bro we appreciate you know you
coming on very very much i think it's
been a very beautiful and very fruitful
discussion honestly i could say it's
been a pleasure and honor talking to you
out of all the guests
uh you know i i can really see you said
you know how genuine we are and i can
truly say that i personally see how
genuine you are and i do appreciate that
very very much um i hope that you know
we can continue to talk uh whether on or
off stream you know if you have any
questions or anything you can always hit
us up uh and if you ever get to the
point where you want to accept islam you
know we do always invite you as you know
we are that is we want to give out so
let's say if i
accept islam you guys would be the first
people idm yes
honestly that's an honor that that truly
is i appreciate it yeah
any funnel words yeah bro we got 244
viewers in the stream so we have to have
at least 655 likes bro i don't know how
that math makes sense but we got it so
smash that like button if you made it
this far go over to youtube ftd facts
and ftd speaks to support brother
leroy's work
and inshallah until next time
with that being said
this has been the realest podcast in the
dunya
so